foreign
[Music]
[Music]
sexiest woman a successful actress in
hit films like Transformers and
Jennifer's Body or the blood drinking
better half of Machine Gun Kelly it's
just a few drops but yes we do consume
each other's blood on occasion for
ritual purposes you definitely know the
name Megan Fox I swear every detail I
have learned about this couple has been
against my will but other than the blood
of her beloved what does the talented
and beautiful Megan Fox eat in a day
well let's find out together hey
everyone I'm Abby sharp welcome to
Abby's kitchen
[Music]
[Music]
in today's video I'll be eating like
actress model nmgk's fiancee Megan Fox
but you all know the drill I'll be
dressing up everything Abby style and
turning into hunger crushing combos that
I actually want to eat now quick
disclaimer that this diet recall was
compiled from primary and secondary
sources so I really can't speak to the
accuracy of Megan's actual diet not that
it really matters because I only am
really using these alleged meals as a
template for teaching gentle nutrition
and for inspiring what I decide to make
for myself now this is just what I ate
on a random day and it's not meant to be
copied or recommended as how you should
ultimately eat always speak to
registered dietitian about your unique
needs and folks don't forget to
subscribe if you are not already hit
that subscribe button ring that Bell
follow me over on Tick Tock and
Instagram there are so much great
content to go around now before we get
too far into things let me hop in here
to talk to you about today's sponsor
Thrive market so the Thrive Market is an
amazing online membership based grocery
store that aims to make Health focused
Specialty Products more affordable and
accessible to everyone you can filter by
over 90 different diets Lifestyles and
values like vegan fair trade BPA free
gluten free and more they are a One-Stop
shop offering foods and snacks
eco-friendly kitchen and cleaning
supplies Beauty items supplements home
goods and so much more they also have an
amazing selection of sustainable Seafood
wine and nutritious snacks my kids love
all the items are less expensive than
traditional retail they price match and
shipping on all orders over forty nine
dollars is free there's also a deals
page on their website that shows you all
the best deals on your favorite products
they have a one month membership option
for twelve dollars a month and a
12-month membership option for 59.95 I
recommend going with the 12 month
membership because it breaks down to
only five dollars a month and if you
don't make back your membership fee in
savings they will refund you the
difference plus it's risk-free so if you
haven't used it within 30 days you can
cancel and get a full refund within 30
days also for every paid membership the
Thrive gifts initiative gives away a
free membership to a low-income family
teacher and Veteran I get so much out of
this membership whenever I'm down in the
States because all my favorite snacks
and all my kids favorite snacks are
available on Thrive and I get such an
amazing deal on all the products so
check out my link in the description
thrivemarket.com Abby sharp to get 30
off of your first order and a free gift
worth up to sixty dollars and get
shopping today alright before we attempt
this diet I want to set the stage for
how Megan eats now according to Insider
Megan Follows the five Factor diet
created by her trainer Harley Pasternak
and as the name implies each element of
the diet revolves around the number five
why the number five that I do not know a
complete pseudoscience mystery but it
makes for a damn Snappy book title
though anyway the protocol involves
eating five meals a day prepared in five
minutes or less and consisting of five
food categories lean protein low GI
carbs healthy fats fiber and sugar-free
Beverages and this rule of fives even
extends to its fitness program which
involves working out five days a week
focusing on five muscle groups for five
minutes each totally easy to remember I
suppose which we love but also kind of a
pretty arbitrary number two built a
whole diet around and even though the
five Factor diet doesn't have any
research to support it specifically the
underlying suggestions do make a lot of
sense I mean maybe the five minute meal
rule is like a bit of a stretch to stay
on theme like I probably spend more than
five minutes just staring in the fridge
deciding what to make but in the grand
scheme of weight loss diets I think it's
a decent plan all right now that we've
got a sense of what to expect from
Megan's five Factor diet protocol let's
get into eating Abby good luck okay it
is 9 A.M over here AKA second coffee of
the day time I'm hoping Megan agrees now
I'm not sure how anything like butt
black coffee Stacks up in Harley's
sugar-free beverage rule but you guys
know how I feel about black coffee it's
a hard pass but let's see how Megan
starts her day the worst thing I put in
my body is coffee once a day I'm sorry
this is coming from the girl who drinks
blood
my life Abby help I got you girl if
coffee is the worst thing that you're
putting into your body I'm kind of
afraid to see what the rest of the day
is going to look like but not only is
coffee one of the most studied edible
substances in the world but we have
ample evidence showing its benefits for
gut bacteria mood cognition exercise
performance and even heart health it is
also one of the most concentrated
sources of antioxidants like polyphenols
so if you don't like coffee don't drink
coffee but let's not demonize a
substance that is so universally loved
seriously it's offensive like don't mess
with my coffee
um I don't typically put any kind of
like sugar in mine but I do love a good
latte and I feel like it needs a little
extra flavor so let's see what I got
today oh
this one is like a limited edition
pumpkin spice just to add a little extra
creaminess and flavor
this is like the best thing I put in my
body
just come on you guys let's do it okay
I'm hungry let's talk about breakfast so
according to Hello magazine Megan
typically has egg whites almonds and
oatmeal and actually this is totally
hunger crush and combo approved and also
five Factor diet approved because we got
some lean protein in our egg whites
we've got some low GI carbs and fiber in
our oatmeal and we've got some healthy
fats in the almonds and then I guess we
got our coffee on the side
but yeah the thought of eating these
three things just like on their own it's
leaving a little to be desired so we are
going to whip up my famous fluffy
protein oats let me show you how we do
it oh it's down and we're gonna add some
of our milk any kind of milk you like
I'm using like a protein based
plant-based milk
looks about right all right
a little bit of cinnamon and give her a
good stir
okay while that's starting to heat up
I've got some egg whites here that I
just separated from my whole eggs
give it a really good whisk until
they're a little fluffy I'm going to
turn down my heat a little bit
and add those whipped egg whites right
into the oats
keep whisking you don't want to scramble
them so you don't want to be too hot all
right I've got some frozen banana here
that's going to add a lot of natural
sweetness
a little extra body
throw that in add a little almond butter
and a touch of vanilla
great okay give it one last whisk
we're going to turn off the heat pop on
a lid and let it finish cooking all
right going down
gotta get it all
I'm gonna add a little more almond
butter on top for a little drizzle
drizzle got some berries
foreign
almonds
for our almond loving Megan
looks pretty good all right let's recap
we've got lots of protein in the almond
butter almonds and the egg whites we
have plenty of high fiber carbs in our
oats Plus in our berries on top I've
also got lots of healthy fats of course
in the almond butter and the almonds it
looks delicious way more satisfying than
like eating all the components
separately in my opinion and I feel like
this is going to give me some good fuel
to work out
um there's a reason this is the number
one recipe on my blog by the way I'm
usually a whole egg girly but this
recipe just like doesn't really work
very well if you're incorporating the
egg yolks because it's the egg whites
that give it that cloud like texture but
I really don't want people to fear whole
eggs so Abby can you give us a rundown
sure thing girl there used to be a lot
of fear mongering around whole eggs
since they're a source of dietary
cholesterol however new research
suggests that dietary cholesterol from
food actually has a very minimal impact
on our blood cholesterol we also know
that most of the eggs nutrition is
contained in the yolk I mean they're
rich in vitamins a d e k folate B12 plus
some unique antioxidants so yeah I'm
going to use the egg yolks to make like
a carbonara later on this week all right
now we are fed and fueled let's take a
look at what Megan does for exercise
twice a week it's hard with babies so I
go twice a week but I do two hour
workouts
um I do like bursts of cardio with
really heavy weights okay yeah circuit
training yeah training so I can get down
for like a cardio sesh and some weights
but a two hour workout
is a hard no not only do I not have that
much time to dedicate to a workout but I
also know what feels good to my body and
a two hour workout sesh ain't it as for
the circuit training the five Factor
protocol involves doing five minutes
each of cardio upper body lower body abs
and a cool down repeated four times not
five times by the way four times like
plot twist I know
but seeing as I only have like 45
minutes before I got to get to work and
like hop on a few calls I'm gonna just
like trim it down to fit in what I can
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
okay so I'm tired and I'm hungry so
let's talk about lunch according to
Hello magazine Megan will usually opt
for salmon sashimi with a side of
edamame and miso soup or some kind of
salad with salmon and according to her
trainer Harley Pasternak she will have
salmon like at least once a day but Abby
what are your thoughts listen we love
salmon it's one of the most
nutrient-rich foods you can eat it's
packed with protein omega-3 fats and
iron but it is possible to have too much
of a good thing since all fish does
contain some Mercury although amounts do
vary significantly between types the
safe intake of mercury is about 0.1
microgram per kilogram of body weight
per day and since salmon specifically is
very low in mercury you could likely
consume up to around 11 to 14 small 3
ounce servings of salmon per week safely
most people consume closer to 4 four to
six ounces of protein in a meal so if
you're consuming a large enough portion
of salmon once a day you could also be
nearing critical levels so of course we
do want to try to focus on protein
variety as often as we can notice I
think we're going to go with the salad
because I'm already hungry right now and
I don't have time to wait for ubereats
but according to E news Megan
specifically likes to top her salad off
with apple cider vinegar because she
says it cleanses out your system
entirely ah
um Abby have we gone over this we have
and we will again folks nothing we eat
or drink cleanses the system like that
is what our detox organs do naturally
every single day when we pee poop sweat
or breathe if apple cider vinegar does
anything to help you detox AKA poop it's
mainly because it theoretically contains
small amounts of the Prebiotic fiber
pectin which can potentially help with
regularity but
eating a whole fiber-rich apple and
drinking some water or you know a fiber
rich salad does a trick too salad we can
do and listen I feel like a salad
obviously needs a dressing and apple
cider vinegar is an amazing part of that
so I'm definitely going to incorporate
it somehow into the recipe if just for
the flavor alone and I feel like we
should put Harley's whole like five
minute rule to the test here and see if
we can build out that balanced salad in
five minutes or less Brody start the
timer
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
yes
I did it I almost cut off a finger
multiple times on multiple vessels but
I hope we made Harley Pasternak proud
minus the fact that I guess we broke a
rule here because we're not supposed to
have white carbs whatever
um but I say we've dressed them up with
tons of hunger crushing compounds here
get out of my way
please let's recap we got lots of fiber
going on with all of our vegetables
obviously plus some extra hummus which I
added in because the combination of just
like vegetables and lettuce and a can of
salmon with some apple cider vinegar on
top sounded nasty AF but we've also got
our protein in the canned salmon
obviously we've got some carbs in these
little chips which by the way
hummus flavored chips they just hit
different
um and lots of healthy fats in the olive
oil the salmon and the hummus and I
added some cheese on there for good
measure so let's get this going
those are actually really good the chips
are keto because your girl needs some
carbs
all right let's talk snack so according
to Pasternak Megan's go-to snack is a
smoothie made with red berries chai tea
almond milk and protein powder
interesting combination but let's try it
I actually really like chai tea but I'm
a little skeptical about this
combination well let's give it a go we
got some red berries
protein powder
almond milk
and
our chai tea
oh
probably don't want
okay let's just try a little a little
shot first
so gross I need to fix this
all right banana all right that should
do that trick
um Greek yogurt got a nice high fat
yogurt here
because it's really lacking body
finish and
maybe for a little nuttiness some hand
parts
I'm basically just gonna try to drown
out the chai tea flavor because it's a
weird combo how she came up with that
one no one will know but then again what
can we expect whose palette is
accustomed to blood
all right take two
much better I mean
it is starting to separate so I'm not
sure what that's about
can still taste the chai tea
not a fan but it's a lot more palatable
and it's probably going to be a lot more
Sage hitting than Megan's version let's
recap what we got we have lots of fiber
in our berries here plus some extra
carbs in our bananas we've got protein
in the protein powder and the Greek
yogurt healthy fats in our hemp hearts
and also in a nice full fat yogurt as
well honestly
it's not the greatest but it's good
enough to get me through dinner
all right just grab the kids they're
already hungry let's talk dinner all
right so according to Harley who is
apparently not just her trainer but also
doubles as the gatekeeper to All Things
Megan's diet if Megan does not have
salmon at lunch she'll have it for
dinner in the form of like sushi or
she'll go with some kind of like chicken
quinoa situation I had salmon for lunch
so let's talk about the chicken option
obviously these are both super
nutritious Foods Chicken is a great
source of lean protein and quinoa
contains both fiber and plant-based
protein but this meal sounds boring as
like I don't really like quinoa on a
good day leave me a comment below if you
guys agree with that statement or if you
think I should like lose my dietitian's
license over that but anyways I don't
like it I just find it like Bland and
kind of like mushy even if you do cook
it right so I'm gonna do my own thing
here I'm Gonna Keep On theme with the
chicken grain combo but I'm gonna do my
own thing and I'm gonna try to turn it
into a hunger crushing combo and I'm
going to also try to stick with the
Harley five minute roll wish me luck
let's make the easiest stir fry you've
ever seen olive oil
in the pan
and a little touch of sesame oil for
some flavor you don't want too much
because it'll just get aggressively
flavored all right
all right just leave it alone
we have Frozen vegetable medley love
that
all going on the pan package of rice
already cooked could not be simpler
damn rotisserie chicken just chopped it
up
down and we'll let that all warm up
with little sauce
teriyaki
good old
bottled variety all right we're going to
finish off with some crunchy cashews and
some sesame seeds this literally took me
five minutes so I mean Harley might be
onto something all right let's recap
this we got carbs in the rice we have
lots of fiber rich veg going on protein
in the chicken and some edamame in the
Frozen mix plus we've got some healthy
fats in our sesame seeds and our cashews
on top I'm super excited about eating
this I mean healthy food does not need
to be complicated and this is great
evidence of that
oh
love it all right let's finish off with
a little bedtime snack because it
wouldn't be the five Factor diet without
a fifth meal in the day I have a feeling
that this is probably the time of day
when Machine Gun Kelly and Megan like
gather around for a little ritualistic
snacky snack but I'm good on that front
let's talk about what we can actually
eat so according to Hello magazine
Megan's usual bedtime snack aside from
blood is just a simple bowl of fruit we
are really living our best life here
folks there is literally nothing that
exciting in this day I've tried my best
to take it up a few notches but speaking
of nothing that exciting the five Factor
diet does actually allow for cheat days
once a week on Sunday as long as it
still follows the rule of five in other
words you still have to have the five
meals a day prepared in five minutes or
less with those five main ingredients I
don't know but I feel like that would
just eat chips and ice cream all day
long because that doesn't require any
prep work at all that said apparently
Megan never cheats but yeah I don't I
don't have cheat days I don't I don't
eat anything fun how long can you
maintain a diet restricted by super
random rules with no fun like that I'm
honestly not usually a fan of the whole
cheat day thing because I think it
really does perpetuate and encourage a
potentially disorderly relationship with
food characterized by kind of like a
yo-yo roller coaster of under eating and
overeating but I'm also equally not a
fan of just like never eating anything
fun so let's make this basic fruit bowl
a lot more fun
Harley close your eyes we got some white
vanilla ice cream that's right uh we got
some berries going down
for some Fiber run away a little drizzle
of almond butter mm-hmm
healthy fats
and some extra
sliced almonds as well
Megan I did this for you in protest over
your very boring restricted diet this
recipe right here slaps
take note
well we made it to the end of a five
factored day well kind of like I
definitely broke some rules I'm sorry
Harley but some of those rules just
really needed to be broken was it the
worst celebrity diet I've ever seen no
was it the best also no I think Harley's
diet concept actually makes a lot of
sense even though it might be a little
more complicated than needs be but
Megan's interpretation
definitely leaves a lot to be desired
and I'll take coffee and white carbs
over strange blood rituals any day and
on that note that's all that I have for
you guys today if you like this video be
sure to give it the thumbs up leave me a
comment below on Whose diet you'd like
to see me try next subscribe to the
channel and I'll see you next time on
Abby's kitchen bye
foreign
[Music]